but tsa is bracing for a record number
of people at airport security
checkpoints around the country this
Thanksgiving nearly 27 million
passengers are expected to be screened
during the holiday period meaning
travelers could face long security lines
but new technology being tested by the
TSA could speed up screenings and
address passenger complaints about
electronics liquids and taking off their
shoes Kris Van Cleave is at Los Angeles
International Airport Chris
what could the future look like for us
flyers well good morning hopefully the
future looks a bit like this now lax is
going to get very busy they expect more
than 3.2 million people to pass through
its checkpoints for Thanksgiving that's
a record and look the TSA knows this is
no one's favorite part of the travel
experience but what they're looking at
is the possible checkpoint of the future
at one u.s. airport that could change
they're also working with researchers to
develop sensors that could be tucked
inside of checkpoints aimed at spotting
explosives and that's something you and
I'll probably never actually see in a
field outside Providence University of
Rhode Island researchers are working on
new ways to detect and stop explosives
popular with terrorists they're
partnering with the Department of
Homeland Security on this sensor they
call it a digital dog nose it'll soon be
the size of a cell phone
or able to be mounted on a drone and can
detect homemade explosives as well or
better than a bomb sniffing dog they've
also created a gel called shmoo that can
surround an explosive or chemical agent
and flash freeze it so it can be safely
removed from a transit hub professor
Jimmy Oxley we think about how to detect
and mitigate the threats for today while
we're still realizing that if we get
really good about getting today's
threats there's going to be a different
threat tomorrow what would that look
like and how would we attack it 2,700
miles away at this new airport
checkpoint in Las Vegas
the TSA s newest technology is being
tested together for the first time with
real passengers they call it their
innovation checkpoint this is a
glimpse into the future of what aviation
security is going to look like Jose
Vania is the director of TSA innovation
task force what we're trying to do is
how do we make that a more seamless
process for the traveling public but not
giving up on security capability what
you see here may not be here in a year
we may bring in new pieces of technology
as passengers approach this innovation
checkpoint they'll see dynamic message
boards next new ID readers can scan your
license to quickly validate your
identity and confirm you're flying that
day without needing to show officers
your boarding pass from their carry-on
bags go to a CT scanner electronics can
stay in and eventually the goal is
liquids will - the new scanners can more
easily see through all the clutter and
bags while it's not quite that scanner
from Total Recall science fiction is
coming alive with these new walk by body
scanners they display a generic male or
female form and flag an area of the body
where there may be a concern the
technology is also better at spotting
nonmetallic threats that a metal
detector might miss the improvement they
really need to make for everybody is
don't take your shoes off right they can
speed it up a little bit more yeah the
ID thing was a little slow it's quicker
it definitely pushes people through a
lot faster tsa is hoping it can take
lessons learn to that checkpoint in
Vegas and very quickly turn them into
airport security reality by 2022 and
some of that technology like the CT
scanners is already being rolled out to
some airports Tony Chris thank you
that's a great piece was the first time
we're getting a look at a lot of that
new technology the idea of a digital dog
nose I love the idea of being one of
those bomb researchers at the University
of Rhode Island out there in the field
all day blowing stuff up I was in the
model rocket Club that's a lot more fun